on retrouve tout de suite notre reporter
4 sa technique
bonsoir 4 ça que peut-on retenir de
l'audition du professeur raoul qui se
poursuit encore un petit peu un oui
c'est ça le docteur house est en
audition depuis 17h il est longuement
interrogé je pense qu' aucun point ne
sera pas examiné durant cette audition
alors comme on connaît le professeur
raoul fin il est toujours il a toujours
un franc parler qu'on lui connaît il
n'épargne personne il n'épargne ni les
institutions ni les fonctionnement des
conseils ni rien du tout et en fait il a
par exemple lancé ce type de phrase
assassine à ce qu'on sait encore traiter
les maladies infectieuses en france un
sens que ça ce qu'on sent que les
conflits d'intérêts où les enjeux
politiques ne vienne empiéter alors
évidemment vous parlez de l'hydroxyde
chloroquine il a défendu son traitement
une fois de plus c'est normal tout en
expliquant qu'il souhaitait une faute
d'avoir interdit le traitement avec cet
anti paludéens alors que en 2019 36
millions de pastilles avaient été
délivrés sans ordonnance
et puis surtout il a dessiné un monde où
les conflits d'intérêts et les mauvaise
organisation empêcher toute bonne
gestion de crise sanitaire et ce faisant
il a livré une bombe selon lui le
conseil scientifique du gouvernement et
gilead le laboratoire qui produit le rem
d hiver qui est un des traitements
employés en france contre le coc vide il
ya un conflit d'intérêts en fait qui l'a
révélé donc je vous propose de l'écouter
moi je vous recommande de faire une
véritable enquête sur gilead terme d'ici
si vous regardez la structure de 10
l'ead comprendrez que c'est quelque
chose qui ne fonctionne qu'avec très
très peu de produits très peu de
personnel et une influence considère que
l'essentiel de sa stratégie basée sur l'
influence
moi j'ai été quand même je vous le
rappelle moi quand j'ai commencé à
parler pour la première fois la
chloroquine ya quelqu'un qui m'a menacé
à plusieurs reprises manière anonyme
j'ai porté plainte et j'ai fini par
trouver que c'était celui qui avait reçu
le plus d'argent de guérilla depuis six
ans le niveau de problème là est à un
niveau de problème sur lequel moi je
vous suggère d'être
tiff c'est pas compliqué de regarder
encore une fois qui a des complices des
revolvers des listings le regard des
listings chez les infectiologues vous
regarde et on a même publié un article
là dessus pour dire écoutez les deux
tiers et on a même fait un article
malicieux en en regardant les gens qui
s'est exprimé dans la presse pour ou
contre la chloroquine et on a match et
ça avec le nombre d'argent qu'ils
avaient reçu 2,2 guinéenne et c'est
parfaitement match et que je dis pas la
causalité et la corrélation sont deux
choses différentes je dis pas qu'il ya
une causalité mais une coïncidence au
sens étymologique donc cesser la même
incidence d'être contre laplantine et de
recevoir l'argent de village
donc je vous suggère très fortement de
vous poser la question de savoir le
niveau
moi je n'avais jamais vu d'un flux ans
d'une seule compagnie sur le
fonctionnement qui de mon sens inclus
dans le monde des choses qui sont bien
au delà de celle du médiator alors ce
conseil scientifique aussi pour didier
rahout n'était pas un puisqu'il n'y
avait pas de spécialiste du coronavirus
et qu'on ne travaillait pas sur des
données alors il a claqué la porte il a
évidemment critiqué la politique de
tests selon lui catastrophique on aurait
pu les mener en rhône alpes
on a empêché les médecins veut le faire
alors que c'était facile et la france
c'est donc privé de phases d'observation
importante de diagnostic était
extrêmement précieux il a également
blâmé le poids énorme des centres
nationaux de recherche qui en fait
intervenait dans la chaîne de décision
et alourdissent et où les processus
selon ils n'ont ni la capacité ni les
compétences pour gérer une crise
sanitaire cette crise sanitaire cette
crise d'épidémie en fait devrait être du
domaine régalien avec la création de
nombreux instituts hospitalo
universitaires voilà ce qu'il faut
retenir de cette audition qui est
toujours en cours là actuellement cette
audition de la commission denquête merci
kkp et manquant dirait en direct de
l'assemblée nationale